but if you learned about men from doing
this kind of work
I learned that
men are men winter men uh
if whatever they're not if they're not
getting something at home they're gonna
go out and look for it
to change the way you see
relationships yeah in your life yeah
even the guy who I'm with right now we
you know he's a man so me and him we
hardly have sex and
I know he's always you know he's like
he'll get mad I'll see him text other
people or I can't get mad about it
because you see what I'm doing but I
still have a little jealousy or
something but we we probably only have
sex once a month and he's like why and I
try to understand like I work this is
what I do for a living I'm not
I'm not trying to come home for a female
yeah yeah and he you know so
I'm sad but yeah it's complicated yeah